[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
Washington accuse Damas au lendemain de
l'attaque chimique en Syrie qui a tué 86
personnes dont au moins 20 enfants
Moscou récuse ses accusations tandis que
français et britanniques pointent
également du doigt le régime de Bachar
al-Assad analyse à suivre la décision de
fermer festenheim reporté le conseil
d'administration de DF devait se
prononcé aujourd'hui mais la plus
vieille centrale nucléaire de France
devra encore attendre sous la pression
de l'État aucun accord n'a pu être
trouvé on en parle dans cette édition à
moins de 3 semaines du scrutin jamais un
premier tour n'a semblé aussi incertain
les écarts se resserrent et la
volatilité de l'électorat pourrait faire
bouger les lignes jusqu'au dernier
moment ce soir nous recevons pour un
débat inédit les porte-paroles des
candidats à la présidentielle emploi
économie internationale la confrontation
des programmes de le de leur candidats
c'est dans un instant et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission sur Twitter hashtprésidentiel
360 pour m'accompagner ce soir Saveria
REC en direct de Solferino le multiplex
c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite je vous le disais en titre
l'administration Trump durcit le face au
régime de Bachar al-Assad rendu
responsable de l'attaque chimique
perpétrée au nord de la Syrie les
États-Unis soulignent aussi la
responsabilité morale de Moscou hoise
Grégoire à la Une de Libération
aujourd'hui l'effroid
86 personnes dont 30 enfants sont morts
lors d'une attaque chimique malgré ces
images le président du kremelin juge in
acceptables les accusations sans preuve
selon lui des pays occidentaux le régime
syrien rejette également en bloc et
persiste il ne serait pas responsable de
l'attaque chimique en Syrie depuis hier
une nouvelle voix se fait entendre
Donald Trump hausse le ton et menace
d'intervenir en
Syrie c'est tout à fait possible et je
vais vous dire c'est déjà le cas mon
attitude vis-à-vis de la Syrie et
d'Assad a nettement changé hier
l'ambassadrice américaine à l'ONU
brandit ses images d'enfants syriens
elle accuse Moscou de dédoiner le régime
de
Damas si la Russie a l'influence qu'elle
prétend avoir en Syrie il faut qu'elle
s'en
servve il faut qu'elle mette un terme à
ces actes atroces combien d'enfants
devront encore mourir avant que la
Russie ne s'en
souci le climat se tend entre les
États-Unis et la Russie vous avez
aujourd'hui un pays qui est la Russie
qui a une stratégie très claire très
cohérente de soutien au régime pour
s'assurer que le régime tienneent en en
alliance avec l'Iran et à l'inverse vous
avez des pays occidentaux qui font des
actes diplomatiques mais finalement
assez peu d'action sur le terrain et
donc dans un contexte comme ça l'équipe
des force est largement favorable à la
Russie les Nations unies dans le cas
syrien ont fait très peu hein c'est
vraiment un des grands échecs
historiques des nations- Unies
aujourd'hui des autopsies en Turquie
confirment bien l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques par le régime syrien mais
combien de temps encore le Conseil de
sécurité sera-t-il le simple spectateur
de ces massacres et puis le chef de la
diplomatie turque critique également la
position de Moscou le soutien de la
Russie à Assad la décision était sans
doute trop sensible politiquement à
moins de 3 semaines du premier tour de
la présidentielle le conseil
d'administration de DF a préféré
reporter le vote qui devait entériner la
fermeture de Fessenheim la plus ancienne
centrale nucléaire du parc français
Sandra
serkera plusieurs centaines de salariés
venus mettre la pression jusqu'au bout
devant le siège de DF et finalement la
fermeture de Fessenheim a été reporté
cet après-midi par le conseil
d'administration de l'entreprise une
première victoire pour les salariés
inquiet par les 2000 emploi menacé alors
que pour eux la centrale est encore en
état de fonctionner c'est quand même une
C nucléaire qui qui était validé comme
étant sûr par l'autorité de sûeté
nucléaire aujourd'hui on a la validation
pour exploitation pendant 10 ans donc il
a aucune raison technique de fer
aujourd'hui donc la seule raison c'est
une raison politique c'était une de
François Hollande un bras de fer entre
l'État et EDF qui dure depuis plusieurs
années la direction a toujours traîné
des pieds à tel point que ce matin
encore c'est Goolen Royal les a rappelé
à l'ordre nous avons maintenant des
centrales qui arrivent à échéance de
leur durée de vie à 40 ans de leur durée
de vie et donc investir dans ces
centrales va coûter beaucoup plus cher
qu'investir soit dans les énergies
renouvelables soit dans les économie
d'énergie et par conséquent l'intérêt de
l'entreprise ça n'est pas de ralentir ce
procè essus la ministre de
l'Environnement souhaitait prendre au
plus vite un décret pour fermer
Fessenheim à la mise en service de l'pr
de flamandville prévue fin 2018 la balle
est maintenant dans le camp du futur
président de la République seul Marine
Le Pen et François Fillon souhaitent
maintenir fenheim en activité et on en
vient maintenant à l'actualité politique
aujourd'hui avec cet appel de
Jean-Christophe cambadellis premier
secrétaire du PS à de la loyauté envers
Benoît amont le bureau national est
réuni ce soir une seul ferino on vas
tout de suite retrouver sur place
Saveria rogek bonsoir Saveria on voit
les premiers élus qui arrivent pour ce
bureau dans quel état d'esprit
sont-ils et bien dphine l'ambiance est
plutôt morose hein ici rue de Solferino
au siège du Parti socialiste la journée
avait déjà plutôt mal commencé avec ce
sondage hein qui donne Benoît amont à
moins de 10 % 9 % Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
siphonne l'électorat de gauche et
s'envole à 17 % c'est ce qu'on entend
maintenant euh chez certains poids Louds
c'est qu'un parti socialiste en dessous
de 10 % des plus un parti capable de
gagner et donc de gérer le pays pourtant
ce matin c'est Michel Sapin qui avait
officialisé son soutien à Benoît amont
un soutien du bout des lèves qui ne
devrait pas donc faire bouger beaucoup
les lignes Stéphane Lefol lui fidèle
parmi les fidèles du président François
Hollande c'est dit lui partager et bien
entre sa fidélité au Parti socialiste
justement et le risque Front national
alors à l'ordre du jour Delphine de ce
bureau national les dernières
invtituraux législatives et dans le
viseur des proches de Benoît amamont non
seulement la trentaine de députés qui a
pariné Emmanuel Macron mais aussi manuel
Vals et ses proches qui le soutiennent
également l'entourage de benamon
voudrait une réaction plus sévère des
sanctions une clarification ce à quoi
Jean-Christophe Cambadelis a dors et
déjà opposé une fin de non recevoir pas
de saint-barelémie pas de chasse au
sorcièr je vous propose d'écouter à ce
sujet-l justement à l'instant Luc
carbounas le sénateur qui vient de
s'exprimer soutien de benoî monont il a
très clairement appelé à voter pour
Emmanuel Macron je regrette ce choix
mais en même temps que ce soit manuel
Vals ou jean-riant vous aurez constaté
que les voix du Parti socialiste
favorable àuel Macron sont très
minoritaires en nombre dans ce qui
compte de responsable socialiste
merci voilà donc pas de chasse aux
sorcières pas de sanction
Jean-Christophe cambadellis qui lance
donc cette après-midi un appel à l'unité
et la loyauté l'unité c'est un peu tard
quand on voit les poids lourds qui ont
déjà rejoint Emmanuel Macron alors dans
ce texte qui est signé par une centaine
de dirigeants du parti le patron du PS
dit refuser de céder à la panique
démocratique pourquoi et bien justement
en vue des prochaines élections
législatives on l'aura compris Delphine
au PS la bataille des législatives a
d'ors et déjà
commencer merci beaucoup saintverrien
pour toutes ces précisions et on vous
retrouvera bien entendu tout au long de
cette édition jamais un premier tour
n'aura paru aussi incertain de jour en
jour les lignes bougent et les écarts se
resserrent entre les candidats ajouter à
cela un nombre d'indécis des plus élevés
il paraît de plus en plus difficile de
dire qui sera au second tour alors avant
d'en parler avec les porte-paroles des
candidat pour savoir quelle stratégie
ils vont adopter ces derniers jours de
campagne voyez ce reportage de Flora
sauvage au coude à coude à l'approche du
premier tour l'écart entre Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen est toujours
aussi serré dans un sondage hlable le
fondateur du mouvement en marche et la
présidente du Front national sont
crédités du même score soit 23,5 %.
jusque la favorie des enquêtes d'opinion
Emmanuel Macron perd de points derrière
eux François Fillon gagne un point à 19
% et Jean-Luc Mélenchon le talon à 17 %
des sondages que le candidat LR veut
prendre avec des pincettes absolument
convaincu que ces sondages sont ils ne
sont pas inexacts ils
sont ils sont ils sont biaisés à la fois
par les par les échantillons par les
questions puis surtout par le climat
politique général à gauche Jean-Luc
Mélenchon prend désormais l'ascendant
sur Benoît ammont le candidat du PS
passe sous la barre des 10 % enfin le
souverainiste Nicolas du pontaignan perd
un point à 4,5 %. Philippe poutau
progresse d'un point à 1,5 % le
centriste Jean Lassal et la candidate de
Lutte Ouvrière natthalie Arto stagne à 1
%. les autres candidats François aselino
et Jacques Cheminade sont crédité de
moins d'un % chacun au second tour
Emmanuel Macron l'emporterait très
largement contre Marine Le Pen
et on va tout de suite ouvrir le premier
débat avec mes invités c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
sur ce plateau Laurent Saim bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
porte-parole d'Emmanuel Macron également
sur ce plateau Philippe daller bonsoir
sénateur les républicains de scène
Saint-Denis vous soutenez François
Fillon dans cette course à l'Élysée éric
ocrel est également avec nous bonsoir
vous êtes coordinateur politique du
programme de la France à j'accueille
également Geoffrey bolet bonsoir vous
êtes conseiller régional Île-de-France
FN et vous êtes responsable du ple outil
dans la campagne de Marine Le Pen
j'accueille enfin Mathieu anotin bonsoir
vous êtes directeur de campagne de
Benoît amont on voit ce contexte
politique Laurent saahm avec ses enquête
d'opinion qui indique un tassement des
intentions de vote pour Emmanuel Macron
mais aussi pour Marine Le Pen on le voit
l'écart se resserre est-ce que vous avez
anticipé cette situation et quelle
stratégie allez-vous adopter ces
derniers jours de campagne écoutez on
adopte une stratégie d'être écoute des
Français depuis le début et surtout de
ne pas faire de triomphalisme c'est une
élection difficile c'est une élection où
on perçoit beaucoup d'anxiété de la part
des classes moyennes beaucoup de colère
on a décidé à en marche que jusqu'au
bout on allait être à l'écoute de ces
classes moyennes de ces classes
populaires pour essayer de leur proposer
autour d'Emmanuel Macron quelque chose
de crédible avec du fond ce soir
Emmanuel Macron fera l'émission
politique sur France 2 et donc encore
une fois rien n'est gagné on se battra
jusqu'au bout jour après jour minute
après minute pour la bataille du premier
vous gardez le même cap dans cette
campagne il y a pas de changement de
stratégie non il y a pas de changement
de stratégie encore une fois on voit que
les gens viennent dans nos meetings que
ils écoutent les propositions d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'il y a des adhérents chaque
jour qu'il y a des gens aussi qui nous
rejoignent chaque jour de tout bord on a
le sentiment que les Français
comprennent qu'on essaie de faire la
politique différemment qu'on essaie de
dépasser les clivages gauche- droite et
qu'on essaie aussi de proposer une
vision positive de la France ma Antin on
voit aujourd'hui cet appel de Christophe
cambadelliss cet appel à la loyauté
alors que le gouvernement est clairement
dispersé dans son soutien à Benoît amont
on sait que le candidat socialiste a
reçu aujourd'hui le soutien de Michel
Sapin un soutien peut-être un peu du
bout des lèvres c'est cette situation de
dispersion du gouvernement de cette
hémorragie vers Emmanuel Macron qui
plombe la campagne de Benoît Hamont
selon vous bon écoutez moi ce que je
veux dire avant tout c'est que ce qu'on
voit ce qu'on ressent hier est encore à
Nancy c'est qu'il y a une vraie énergie
sur le terrain euh qu'on ne retrouve pas
je je le vois bien dans les intentions
de vote je sais les lire comme tout le
monde euh mais ben écoutez pourquoi ça
je ne sais pas euh ce que je sais c'est
que Benoît amont comme tous ceux qui
sont autour de lui on n'a pas l'habitude
de faire de la politique par rapport euh
au sondage et mais plutôt par rapport à
nos convictions et donc nos convictions
ne changent pas en fonction des sondages
donc on va les continuer à les présenter
à les affirmer haut eff fort parce qu'on
pense que c'est la bonne solution euh
pour le pays et après ma fois le seul
juge de PAI qu'on reconnaîtra c'est pas
la démocratie son d'agir à la petite
semaine c'est le vote du 23 avril et du
7 mai ouais Éric ocrel on voit au
contraire que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
plutôt l'homme en forme dans cette
élection il y a une dynamique autour du
candidat de la France en soumise vous
dites merci au Parti socialiste pour
cette bonne forme de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
alors je vois pas ce que vient faire le
Parti socialiste là-dedans non nous on
dit surtout merci à certains indice très
concret qui confirme effectivement les
tendances des sondages même si pour nous
considère que c'est un peu des
horoscopes mais manifestement c'est de
ça dont on parle donc il vaut mieux être
auut placé et en progression c'est le
fait que nous avons eu 70000 adhérents
en 10 jours sur notre plateforme JLM
2017 en plus et qu'on les voit
effectivement sur le terrain par
milliers je crois que tout le monde
personne en ira l'afflux des personnes
qui viennent dans les meeting et ce que
nous remarquons surtout c'est que nous
avons et moi c'est la première fois que
je vois à ça au moins 30 % des gens qui
viennent pour se convaincre qui viennent
chercher des raisons de voter et
j'allais dire que en ressortant souvent
ils sont convaincu voilà notre atout
c'est notre programme ça fait des mois
qu'on le prépare il est pas improvisé on
peut pouvez le critiquer ou pas mais il
est cohérent il est prêt à gouverner le
pays a changer les institutions et je
crois que c'est ça dont les gens se
rendent de plus en plus compte que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est une rupture
tranquille c'est une révolution
citoyenne issu pacifique qui lui ne part
pas en guerre contre tout le monde
contre des ennemis intérieurs extérieurs
et qui compte bien les répartir la
richesse parce que c'est le seul
programme à ma connaissance parmi les
candidats aptes à le 2ème tour qui
propose justement d'aller chercher
l'argent qui est parti depuis 30 ans
dans les bénéfices non investis et de le
remettre dans les revenus du travail de
l'intérêt général ouais Geoffrey baet
est-ce que la campagne de Marine Le Pen
est aussi en train de s'essouffler on
voit qu'elle a eu du mal à capitaliser
notamment sur les derniers débats
télévisés et je le disais à l'instant
les écarts se resserrent entre elle et
Emmanuel Macron non non pas du tout en
plus dans les derniers débats ces sujets
étaient au centre donc on va dire plus
la campagne a tendance à tourner autour
d'elle ses adversaires l'attaquent et
c'est normal euh non nous et puis en
plus les sondages en fait elle est
relativement stable depuis le début on
est solidement ancré on sent sur le
terrain une vraie dynamique nos meetings
sont pleins euh une influence une assez
importante l'ambiance sur le terrain est
remarquable marine est très populaire on
le voit sur le marché tous les jours
donc non nous on est on est au contraire
on est très serein on constate cette
solidité effectivement c'est un peu plus
volatile je crois dans le camp en face
notamment chez chez Monsieur Macron et
non nous sommes convaincus précisément
parce que depuis le début on fait une
campagne de fond sur des propositions
claires on on y reviendra sans doute en
parlant d'emploi tout à l'heure euh qui
convaincent les Français et on met au
centre voilà les vraies questions sur
lesquelles les Français on se déterminer
au cours de ce scrutin qui détermine
l'avenir de la France donc là on est on
est vraiment serein et on constate une
solide dynamique sur sur le terrain très
solide philippe Dallier c'est vrai que
cette volatilité de l'électorat c'est
indécis c'est une des clés de ce scrutin
le camp fioniste mise sur un vote caché
ça peut faire une élection ça ce vote
caché selon vous écoutez d'abord ce que
tout le monde a constaté c'est que
énormément de français on nous dit que
plus d'un tiers des Français ne savent
pas pour qui ils vont aller voter et
nous sommes à de semaines un peu plus du
premier tour donc jamais la situation
n'a été aussi indécise depuis le début
nous disons que à partir du moment où
nous allons parler des problèmes de fond
parce que jusqu'à présent la campagne a
plutôt tourné sur d'autres sujets mais à
partir du moment où nous allons parler
des 3 millions et demi de chômeurs que
nous laisse François Hollande et dont
Emmanuel Macron pas fautif lui-même
François Fillon justement du fait qu'on
parle pas du programme de fond encore ce
matin c'était lui qui ramenit toujours à
la question des affaires à partir du
moment où nous allons parler des 2200
milliards d'euros de dettes que les
gouvern
de Monsieur Hollande vont nous avoir
laissé des 70 milliards de déficit
budgétaire bien oui les Français vont
également se poser des questions et je
pense que face au programme et j'espère
qu'on va effectivement en discuter
Emmanuel Macron vous nous disiez que il
écoutait les Français mais ce qu'on lui
demande puisqu'il prétend être président
de la République c'est de développer les
propositions qu'il met sur la table et
c'est le grand flou les gens ne
comprennent pas quelle est la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est le candidat
attrape tout à droite à gauche vous
l'avez dit comm
une majorité nous n savons rien pour Fr
national mélchon du point de vue de
l'économie peu près les mêmes solution
on pour don au candidat du Parti
socialiste effectivement aujourd'hui il
est au trè fond des sondages parce qu'il
paye la politique qui a été
conduite trs
intéress jour une alliance un peu
stratégique entre François Fillon et le
Front national par non non mais vérit ré
c'est vraiment un cauchemar plutôt en
tout cas moi ce que je peux vous dire il
y a beaucoup de fonds dans notre
programme qui sont faits par des gens
comme moi venant de la société civile
qui n'ont jamais fait de politique et
qui croi qu'il y a une nouvelle
proposition qui peut marcher en France
avec des Français det non pas du tout je
vais vous les donner très précisément
monsieur absolument et d'ailleurs je
vais répondre en même temps aux ATT fait
sur Emmanuel Macron c'est comme François
Hollande Emmanuel Macron je le rappelle
a démissionné pour dire qu'il était en
désaccord avec François Hollande il
propose de faire des choses nouvelles
par rapport à François Hollande il
propose une réforme de la retraite il
propose une révolution encore une fois
du système de la formation
professionnelle il propose encore une
fois de refaire complètement le code du
travail de réformer la
manièreire complètement on pas bien
compr en tout casvelpp je peux
développer non mais attendez laissez-moi
parler parce que moi je crois beaucoup
en la politesse dans la démocratie donc
je vous dis des choses concrètes on a
fait un diagnostic précis on a écouté
avec Emmanuel Macron et beaucoup de gens
qui ont travaillé avec nous de manière
bénévole les préoccupations des français
à partir de ce diagnostic on a fait un
cadrage
Bud je pense que encore une fois il faut
faire l'effort dans cette élection qui
est très sérieuse parce que finalement
cette élection au-delà des mots c'est
aussi une définition de la société pour
les 5 prochaines années Emmanuel Macron
a sur son site en marche et tout le
monde peut voir ça et bien sur les
thèmes précis l'éducation la santé la
sécurité des réponse extrêmement précise
pour l'instant rien moi ce qui ce qui ce
qui me gêne un petit peu dans ce débat
mais je sais que c'est un débat qu'on a
depuis maintenant qu'on essaie en tout
cas d'avoir parce que c'est vrai que
monsur Dalier quand même je veux bien
ENF le pompier pyoman ou l'roseur arrosé
peu importe enfin serait la moindre des
choses soit pas vous qui vous plaignez
du mauvais climat de cette campagne je
pense qu'on av raison de s' l'avons sub
et on
pas Siler les journaliste quand vous
remettez en cause l'indépendance de la
justice c'est vous qui dites
ça moi ce que je veux dire là pour je
pense ce qui est important cette
élection c'est qu' de la clarté chacun
réclame de la clarté de la clarté de la
clarté mais oui faisons de la clarté je
vous le dis madame Aï dites clairement à
quoi correspond la réforme des retraites
que vous proposez parce que là on entre
dans les vrais sujets et la réforme des
retraites que vous proposez la réforme à
point entre guillemets ça change j'ai
bien lu le programme d'Emmanuel Macron
effectivement c'est un grand changement
effectivement ça n'a à peu près rien à
voir avec une réforme de gauche de d'un
système de solidarité c'est un système
où pour 1 € cotisé vous avez un point à
la fin c'estàd que Ch cotisé donnera
droit au même droit avec att dire
finirad qu même si préfrez
voilà la déclinaison de
ça ça ve dire que si vous cotisez peu
parce que vous avez eu des carrières
hachées notamment souvent c'est le cas
des femmes ou alors si vous avez des
carrières hachées parce que vous avez
fait beaucoup d'intérim par exemple dans
votre vie et bien vous vous retrouverez
avec une retraite de rien du tout à la
fin c'est ça la
réité les propositions de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon justement à nous elles sont
simples c'est de revenir à une retraite
à 60 ans avec 43 années de cotisation et
que pas un seul sm un seul retraité dans
ce pays touche en dessous du SMIC voilà
ce que nous disons à ma connaissance
nous sommes les seuls à faire cette
proposition et ce que je remarque
puisqu'on parlait de l'emploi c'est que
moi j'ai lu le programme de Monsieur
Macron j'ai le programme de monsur
Fillon Madame Le Pen et tout ça et bien
sûr de Monsieur amont sur la question
par exemple de l'augmentation des
salaires nous sommes les seuls à pas
aller les chercher sur les cotisations
sociales comme Monsieur Macron monsieur
Fillon et Madame Le Pen et ni à les
chercher sur une solidarité nationale à
travers par un complément de revenu
d'existance nous sommes les seuls à
penser qu'il faut aller les chercher sur
les bénéfices qui depuis 30 ans
s'accumulent encore l'année dernière
plus 21 % des bénéfices du 440 quand la
richesse nationale n'a augmenté que de 1
% donc c'est ça qu'il faut aller les
chercher nous sommes parmi les nous
sommes les seuls à penser qu'il faut
totalement revenir sur l'histoire de la
la loi travail et ne pas augmenter le
fait continu à inverser les normes parce
que nous avons remarqué là encore que
Monsieur Macron monsieur Fillon et
également Madame Le Pen sont pour des
accords négociés par branche ou par
entreprise et sont pour la fin des 35 he
nous nous sommesenir au 35 he voà
nousassumons parfait vous je remarque
les points commun vousz pas avec emmanu
Macron les 35 he il veut pas
toucherou laissez-moi interrom
pas moi j'ai pas interrompu tout à
l'heure tout le monde d'accord donc nous
sommes les nous sommes nous sommes les
seuls en tout cas parmi face à à Le Pen
Fillon et Macron a estimer qu'il faut
revenir à 35 or au CDI et à attaquer le
le le temps partiel qui est une
véritable problème dans le pays et ainsi
de suite sur les questions y compris
d'austérité je pense que nous sommes les
seuls à penser qu'il faut une relance de
l'activité et non plus d'aller étrangler
les Français avec des dé baisses des
dépenses publiques dont on voit le
résultat en Guyane Geoffre bolet ensuite
oui monsieur sauf que là vous ne nous
dites pas comment recréer de l'emploi si
je vous dis comment l'emploi vous
réduisez le temps de travail vous allez
prendre de l'argent ce que vous fait pas
la fin alors allezy vol laisse-moi par
s'il vous plaît
monur dem laisse
parler écoutez moi jeis vous exposer
surtout com Marine Le Pen compteréer de
l'emploi notre pays donc il s'agit de
relancer lativité et c'est la seule qui
a un programme cohérent complet en deux
volets il y a d'abord une dimension
macro-économique où il faut évidemment
se libérer des carcans européen pour
avoir le droit de refaire du patriotisme
économique c'estàd retrouver un état
stratège et on a un exemple terrible là
dans l'actualité vous voulez aussi
retirer la loi de travail c'est un point
commun
avecendrai l'état stratège avec cet
exemple actuel dans l'actualité on voit
que saint-nazer est abandonné les
chantiers de saint-nazer à leur
concurent italien c'est scandaleux c'est
c'est aussi faire du patriotisme
économique retrouver une monnaie
nationale pour la compétitivité et dans
le même temps il s'agit de redonner de
l'oxygène au principaux acteurs de
l'économie je reviendrai aux principaux
acteurs de l'économie à savoir les
ménages et les entreprises les ménages
en leur redonnant du pouvoir d'achat
notamment par une baisse des trois
premières tranches de l'impôt sur le
revenu de 10 % la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentes et surtout leur
majoration prime de pouvoir d'achat
l'augmentation de 100 € de du
minimum la baisse de 5 % des tarifs
réglementé de l'énergie et là c'est
encore la faute de l'Union européenne et
je termine là-dessus et pour les
entreprises évidemment tout réorienté
vers les TPE PME notamment le cice les
allègements de charg et baisser l'impôt
sur les sociétés de 33 à
24% ça c'est un programme concret
cohérent qui touche à tout et qui s'arrê
pas sur un petit point pour financer
vous fait payer l'éco aux enfants
étrangers oui au
frtionun
je pense que le Front National a juste
oublié de nous dire que il préconise la
sortie de l'euro et la sortie de
l'Europe
pas si vous pensez qu'ave cela vous
allez rendre service aux entreprises
françaises je pense que vous vous
trompez lour dans cette campagne
électorale il y a un seul candidat qui a
le courage de dire au français que la
situation de ce pays est extrêmement
grave 2200 milliards d'euros de dett et
70 milliards de déficit du simple budget
de l'État on pourrait parler du déficit
du régime des retraites et je rappelle
d'ailleurs que les seules réformes qui
ont été faites dans ce pays ont été
faites par François Fillon que personne
ne les a jamais voté et on nous dit
aujourd'hui qu'avec le système à point
ça améliorer les choses absolument pas
c'est juste un autre mode de calcul vous
ne proposez rien qui règle le problème
du déséquilibre du système des retraites
et nous savons et nous avons le courage
de le dire qu'il faudra aller
progressivement vers 65 ans et nous
disons également qu'il faut revaloriser
les plus petites retraites elles ont été
bloquées par les gouvernements de
François Hollande et c'est injuste donc
nous proposons également de revaloriser
les petites retraites et c'est la même
chose sur bien des points et c'est là où
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas cohérent la
dernière laissez-moi terminer madame le
plus bel exemple de ce candidat attrape
tout sa proposition de suppression de la
taxe d'habitation pour 80 % des Français
est-ce que vous savez combien ça coûte
madame 10 milliards d'euros par an
engagé devant laamf à
justement des collectivités mais
compensé par qui alors al on va creuser
alors j'y viens ça fait 50 milliards
d'euros sur le quinquena et Emmanuel
Macron nous dit qu'il va faire 60
milliards d'économie mais où est la
cohérence du discours d'Emmanuel Macron
d'un côté on ne touche pas aux 35 heur
on ne touche pas aux retraites on
supprime la taxe d'habitation et vous
nous dites qu'on va aller vers
l'équilibre budgétaire et la réduction
de la dette qui peut croire un programme
développé ainsi c'est le candidat
attrape tout et vous vous essayz de
faire prendre aux gens des vessis pour
des lanternes et ils sont en train de
rendre te je pense alors moi je crois
que les Français s'intéressent beaucoup
à ce qui se passe et je vais vous donner
des chiffres précis d'abord je voudrais
dire que on m'a invité pour parler de
politique étrangère donc on y viendra on
y viendra on
restéc en même temps je considère que le
sujet sont extrêmement importants et
avec les équipes d'en marche on a fait
un cadrage budgétaire extrêmement précis
il y aura 60 milliards qui seront fait
d'économie sur les 5 ans avec 50
milliards d'investissement au départ
parce que avit pas les 50 milliards de
taxe d'habitation à ce moment la taxe
d'habitation 80 % des Français ne la
payera plus ça coûte 50 milliards le
financez comment vous arrêtez pas alors
vous êtes t les deux
pourisserpy avec des ch extrêmement
précise il y aura une baisse il y aura
une baisse de prélèv différence un qui
pour l'augmentation de la CSG l'autre
pourmentation de la
tval tout le mond est pour
l'augmentation des impôts sur ce plateau
pour
augmenter s' vous plat on laisse
Laurence
termin voler s'il vous plaît allez-y
Laurence de manière très fractuelle il y
aura une baisse des prélèvements
obligatoires à hauteur de 20 milliards
d'euros à savoir une baisse des taxes
des impôts des cotisations l'impôt sur
les sociétés passera de 33.3 % à 25 %
c'est la moyenne européenne ensuite le
crédit d'impôt compétitif éit emploi
transformé en allègement pérenne des
cotisations pour les entreprises toute
châe partronale sera supprimée au niveau
du SMIG ce qui veut dire que pour les
salariés du SMIG et c'est la majorité de
la population et on en a conscience les
gens souffrent en France les gens
veulent avoir un nouveau pouvoir d'achat
et bien on pense à eux avec un 13e mois
pour les salariés du SMIG avec une
augmentation de 50 % de la prime
d'activité oui mais vous savez moi je ne
maîtrise pas complètement ce que vous
faites depuis 20 ans tout
e si vous ne maîtrisez rien il vaut
mieux ne pas venir sur un plateau pour
nous expliquerise g je maîtrise les gens
qui cro au renouveau de
laps oui absolument c'est le salaire
minimum et je peux vous donner
exactementir par on voir
lesand je viens d'écouter pendant 5
minutes non mais je voudrais simplement
dire quelque ch très rapidement c'est
toujours très facile de dire qu'on a pas
de fonds on a beaucoup de fonds et on
prend ces élections très au sérieux
voilà c'est ce que je veux vous dire le
message est passé on va continuer ce
débat mais d'abord je vous propose de
voir justement et bien les résultats de
notre sondage et les propositions des
candidats pour relancer l'économie et
lutter justement contre le chômage et on
continue ce
débat l'emploi au cœur des
préoccupations des Français interrogés
22 % d'entre eux estiment que la
délocalisation est la cause principale
du chômage un point derrière les
Français pointent du doigt la situation
économique et les aides financières qui
n'incitent pas à travailler à 19 % ils
estiment aussi que les cotisation
sociale des employeurs seraient trop
élevé les Français interrogés donnent
leur avis sur les deux derniers quinena
et se montrent sévère seulement 22 %
pensent que Nicolas Sarkozi a le mieux
agi en matière de lutte contre le
chômage tandis que 16 % opte pour
François Hollande finalement une large
majorité 62 estime qu'aucun des deux
présidents n'a un bon bilan pour faire
baisser le chômage les Français
accordent d'abord leur confiance aux
petites et moyennes entreprises à 85 %
puis aux très petites à 82 lorsqu'on
évoque les grandes entreprises cette
confiance chute à 48 mais le dernier du
classement est PUL emploi seul 23 % des
Français lui font confiance pour créer
des emplois les Français interrogés ont
exprimé leur adhésion à différentes
mesures proposées en tête à 38 % la
réduction des charges des entreprises
sur l'ensemble des salaires les autres
priorités concernent la formation
professionnelle autre question posée qui
parmi les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle est le plus capable
d'améliorer la situation en matière
d'emploi Emmanuel Macron se détache à 25
%. il est suivi de prês par Jean-Luc
Mélanchon à 20 % et Marine Le Pen à 19
les autres candidats sont loin derrière
entre 1 et 3 % des choix concernant leur
proposition 64 % des Français se montent
très favorabl à l'abrogation des lois
Macron et elcomerie la même proportion
voudrait la création d'un impôt sur le
travail réalisé par les machines enfin
une majorité soutient la dégressivité
des allocations ces promesses issues du
programme des candidats ont fortement
convaincu les interrogés Mathieu anottin
on voit bien que les thèmes forts de
Benoît amont dans cette campagne le
revenu universel la taxe sur les robots
la reconnaissance du burnout comme
maladie professionnelle ça concerne le
travail mais cela ne trouve pas
visiblement d'écho dans la population on
le voit dans ce sondage le candidat du
Parti socialiste a-t-il la perdu la
confiance justement de la gauche sur ce
terrain de la lutte contre le chômage
alors c'est c'est je ne tire pas du tout
le même enseignement vous du sondage
qu'on vient de voir je pense justement
que toutes ces questions que Benoît Amon
a posé sont au cœur des préoccupations
des Français à la limite c'est une
interrogation que nous on doit avoir
c'est que les réponses qu'on a proposé
n'ont peut-être pas été assez entendu
assez comprises et c'est pour ça qu'on
veut redoubler d'effort il y a de la
contradiction on voit bien c'est vrai
que les gens sont à 64 % favoraable à la
taxe robot pourtant il ne soutiennent
pas Benoît amont quand il s'agit de
faire confiance à celui qui serait le
plus capable on gagne la bataille des
idées et après la bataille des idées se
retranscrira aussi est-ce que tout à
fait ce qu'on ressent sur le terrain
c'est que aujourd'hui on participe
activement à gagner cette bataille des
idée dans dans la campagne notamment sur
cette question du travail et la place du
travail dans notre société mais que ça
ne se traduit pas en vote et ben c'est
je pense dû aussi à un quelque chose une
sorte de blocage psychologique au sein
de l'électorat de gauche qui est rentré
finalement perdant dans dans cette
bataille et moi j'ai envie de leur dire
il suffit d'y croire voilà votez pour
votez pour vos convictions oui demain
quand on voit qu'il y a une mécanisation
qui est de du travail notamment dans les
dans les services qui va grandissante il
faut que l'on avente de nouvelles
solution pour financer notre protection
sociale de demain voilà et que taque sur
les robots c'est pas une comment dire un
délire qui est né dans la tête de Bono
amont Bill Gates aujourd'hui affirme que
c'est une solution nécessaire Barack
Obama il fait référence dans son
discours quand il quitte la maison
blanche il dit que la principale menace
pour l'équilibre social du monde c'est
la mécanisation la robotisation du
secteur des services qui va faire
disparaître des emplois par millions et
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
invente de nouvelles solution et c'est
ce que propose Benoît amont la taxation
sur les robots c'est une manière
intelligente de financer justement la
protection Suelle de demain le revenu
universel qu'on a souvent caricaturé
comme étant une sorte de prime à la
fénontise mais qui n'est pas du tout ça
qui est aujourd'hui manière immédiate de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat benamon
c'est le seul candidat qui propose une
solution concrète pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat au salariés le 1er
janvier 2018 et notamment à tous ces
travailleurs pauvres dans notre notre
pays qui travaillent et qui ne vivent
pas bien de leur travail Philippe d on a
vu François fon arrive qu'en 4e position
justement quand il s'agit et bien de
citer l'homme politique qui pourrait
redresser la situation du pays il est
inaudible sur son programme économique
est-ce que c'est pas aussi un peu de sa
faute encore ce matin on voyait qu'il
revenait de lui-même sur le terrain des
affaires en disant et bien qu'
poursuivrait tous ceux qui s'en étai
pris à sa femme il a dit j'ai les noms
j'ai les personnes j'ai les dates et ce
que les candidats Benoît amont ou
Emmanuel Macron qui a été ministre de
François Hollande vientnent nous
expliquer maintenant ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour retrouver le plein emploi ça
ne manque pas de sel parce que c'est 1
million de chômeurs de plus le quinquen
qui vient franis F vous m'interromp
c'est parce que je vous dis des vérités
vous
m'interom 1 million madame de chôur en
plus qu'est-ce que on fait les
gouvernements successifs écraser les
entreprises et les particuliers d'impôt
les entreprises ont perdu en
compétitivité pouvez pas dire le
contraire c'est en fin de quinena que
François Hollande s'est réveiller et
Emmanuel Macron plaidait alors également
pour une réforme du Code du travail et
maintenant il en vient à nous dire que
finalement non il touchera pas au 35 he
nous nous disons très clairement qu' il
faut redonner de la compétitivité à nos
entreprises 40 milliards de baisse de
charge effectivement nous le disons et
en contrepartie il y aura une Haus de la
TVA le taux de 20 % passera à 22 % il il
faut toucher au code du travail dans les
sondages et vous n'en dites rien là 82 %
des Français pensent qu'en matière
d'emploi nous n'avons pas tout essayé
oui nous disons la même chose il y a de
grands pays européens et en dehors de
l'Europe qui ont effectivement
libéralisé le code du travail baisser
les charges qui pèsent sur les
entreprises et qui ont obtenu des
résultats et c'est ce que nous proposons
alors c'est peut-être moins populaire
que de proposer le revenu universel en
se demandant où est-ce qu'on trouve les
30 ou 40 milliards qui servent et c'est
peut-être moins attractif qu'Emmanuel
Macron qui maintenant propose de ne rien
changerite
par plus que 35 milliards pris dans la
poche des Français simplement vous poser
une question très simple et vous allez
me répondre avec le plus d'honnêteté
possible
pour est-ce que non je vousz débat 5
tout monde P est-ce que vous pensez que
François Fillon par rapport au pouvoir
d'achat des classe moyenne en ce moment
est crédible par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé s'est mise en examen question
ça
domine je comprends bien que vous
souhaitiez que les 15 derniers jours de
campagne se passe là-dessus mais
voyez-vous il est temps de mettre les
cartes sur la et que les Français
comprennent quelle politique veulent
mener les uns et les autres et le
problème de Macron c'est
qu'effectivement personne ne comprend
aujourd'hui ni à droite ni à gauche ce
qu'il propose alors l'image l'image et
les communiants c'est très bien mais
c'est pour gouverner la France pour 5
ans et pour évit madame que la France
aille dans le TR et vousz très
rapidement la sincérité c'est très bien
aussi en politique al alors par rapport
je ne prends pas de leçon ni chez vous
chez moi je dis simplement que la
sincérité et l'honnêteté ce sont des
choses qui sont rares et qu'on défend
avec passion par rapport au travail
Emmanuel Macron est le seul candidat qui
défend qui défend vraiment il veut
rétablir la courbe du chômage la faire
descendre son objectif non nonendez son
objectif c'est 7 % de chômage il l'a dit
euh ce sont les Français qui attendez ce
sont les Français qui travaillent il va
supprimer le RSI qui est quelque chose
d'extrême
encore une fois 0% des Français ne
payeront pas la taxe d'habitation il
veut réformer
profond réformer profondément Lee
travail exonérer les cotisations
sociales des heures supplémentaires voil
ce sont des propositions
concresends réalité je disisure plus
disp réité les programmes sont proches
parce que ce que vous avez proposé c'est
ce que vient de faire le gouvernement
Hollande d'accord alléger
les all allez-y allez-yy on peut dire un
mot dans cette émission d'accord donc
c'est ce qui a été fait avec le cice je
rappelle 48 milliards chaque emploi créé
a coûté 280000 € ce qui a été fait par
le gouvernement de Monsieur Sarkozy qui
a été fait par le gouvernement de
Monsieur Holland auquel participait
monsieur Macron la question toujours de
baisser les dépenses publiques comme
imposer ces fameuses règles de 3 %
d'austérité impos posé par Berlin et par
Bruxelles dont on souffre depuis des
années qui ne correspondent pas à notre
économie donc il faut arrêter que les
politiques ont été appliquées depuis 10
ans qui sont les même qui sont des
politiques d'austérité monétaristes et
des politiques de l'offre où soi-disant
pour établir la compétitivité on essaie
de favoriser vous savez c'est la fameuse
phrase les profits d'aujourd'hui seront
les investissements de demain et les
emplois d'après-demain c'est Schmid qui
disait ça sauf que ça fait 30 ans que ça
dure et que le chômage n'a jamais été
aussi haut donc ce qu'il faut faire
c'est au contraire de remettre de
l'argent de relancer l'activité y
compris en terme de dépenses publi là où
c'est nécessaire et on voit que c'est
partout nécessaire parce que Monsieur
Macron j'ai lu le programme propose de
baisser par exemple les aides des
collectivités territoriales monsieur
Fillon propose 100 milliards mais
disons-le au guyanais par exemple il y
aura pas d'aide supplémentaire avec des
des projets de ce typelà donc nous nous
sommes pour relancer l'économie à partir
des dépenses publiques nous sommes je
l'ai dis pour relancer d'augmenter les
salaires en en allant chercher sur les
marges des bénéfices et aider les PME
qui qui auraiit des problèmes avec un
fond de solidarité inter entreprise
parce que effectivement elles n'ont pas
à payer pour tous ceux qui depuis des
années font des bénéfices euh à partir
au moment où elles appliquent des des un
droit du travail le CDI et cetera et
nous sommes aussi pour faire en sorte
que le carcan de l'Union européenne nous
puissions effectivement le lever et pour
ça nous comptons sur le fait que la
France deuxème puissance économique en
Europe renégocie enfin avec ses
partenaires sur la base à la fois de
désobéissance quand c'est nécessaire
pour appliquer notre programme sur la
base de d'une Europe qui sera tournée
vers le program si c'est pas possible
nous avons un plan B parce que on ne
peut plus continuer comme c'est cas depu
10 an le plan B ça ser la sortie
unilatérale avec les pays qu'il voudront
mais nous pensons que le plan marcheront
parce que si la France demain si la
France demain veut se faire entendre de
ses partenaires l'Allemagne la Hollande
on vient de le voir les pays du Sud
n'ont pas intérêt à la politique qui
sévit aujourd'hui depuis des années et
je pense que l'Allemagne y compris il
verrait il verrait à de à deux fois
avant de penser qu'il faut en finir avec
l'Union européenne donc nous nous
pensons que nous avons les moyens une
méthode de pression de rapport de force
géopolitique pour changer le carcan de
l'Union européenne parce queeectivement
cette idée du Plan B Geoffre B il l'
repris il le pique monsieur c'est pas
nous qui vous copions sur
l'uropeous Madame Le Pen est parti du
SOR de l'
plan
prramment l'Union pose un problème Maur
c'est pour il est important que cette
question soit toujours au centre du
débat il faut s'en libérer par exemple
si vous donnez si vous voulez donner
l'avantage aux entreprises françaises
dans l'accès au marché public si vous
voulez organiser une politique digne
d'un état stratège pourindustrialiser
pour empêcher que nos flurons soi
rachetés par des groupes étrangers et
cetera il faut évidemment se libérer des
règles de l'Union européenne et ça ne
souffrira pas à 10 ans de négociation il
faut fixer les objectifs l'Union
européenne accepte tant mieux elle se
réforme complètement et elle change elle
refuse on sort
diff bien sû monsieur le RoyaumeUni l'
fait il a posé les TER comm ça il sort
de l'Union
européenne pas
dans trs bien ila bien mieux que nous
perspectives
par tout le monde parle aussi en même
temps c'est un peu problématique et tout
à l'heure vous parliez de de l'emploi de
la dette enfin vous avez une
coresponsabilité absolue votre bilan je
vous le rappelle aussi 600 milliards 600
milliards d'euros de dette et 1,1
million de chôur supplémentair
exactement comme François Hollande donc
vous n'avez aucune autorité aucune
crédibilité pour prétendre redresser
l'emploi relune monsieur je suis
désolé je comprends mais c'est votre
bilan qu'est-ce qu'elle propose pour les
salaires Marine Le Pen nous l'avons dit
il faut d'abord relancer l'activité mais
véritablement parce que c'est pas
uniquement en augmentant le SMIC amé
comment on fait comme ça mais j'éis le
seul avoir vous donner une position
complète avec de volets macroéconomiques
on se libère des règlesunion eurne pour
faire un de politique que je vous ai dit
protectionisme intelligent patriotisme
économique réxygène réxygne économique
il faut impérativement donner du pouvoir
d'
franis votre programme économique vous
êtes pour diminuer de 18 milliards publ
monsieurondur vous inventez vous êtes
dans le mensonge permanes le menong
perman nousmes pour faire des économies
sur la
maise nous assumons notamment sur
l'Union européenne la frae fiscale la
fraude sociale l'immigration donc ça oui
nous supprimons les mavais global
nousunionadistration maaise dép
publimmigrationaise éanger c'est
mauvais compris dans la mauvaise dépense
publique du Front national je le
rappelle dans leur programme comme je
dis tout à l'heure il y a quand même
l'école gratuite pour les enfants
étrangers qui sont en France voilà et ça
c'est écrit le fait que les salari
pouront pas 2 an
béfation économies Mame le ça fait parti
voation
risir sur vous hésitez sur EUR vouis
revenir sur le sujet de l'Europe voà je
suis c'est un une des divergences qui
est apparu lors des débats précédents
que nous avons avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avec ici avec R crocrel son représentant
je pense que cette stratégie qui dit
plan a sinon plan B on sort ça amène à
quelqu'un disait à un plan C qu le plan
conséquence immédiatement parce que on
ne peut pas imaginer demain régler les
problèmes par exemple comme ce de la
transition énergétique nécessaire juste
à l'échelle française donc la question
de l'appartenance à l'Union européenne
on bazard pas des dizaines d'années de
construction
européenne laiss
finir la méthode moi je vous la dire la
Mée la méode non vous avez pas la
méthode c'est celle de la conviction la
méthode c'est celle de la conviction et
celle du combat politique et oui je
pense qu'il y a un impétif et pour la
prière fois excusez-moi pour la première
fois nous avons l'opportunité qu'il y
ait en Allemagne une victoire du camp
social démocrate du camp de la gauche
qui permet d'imaginer un arc d'alliance
différent de retrouver une forme
d'alignement des planètes pour redonner
du sens à l'Europe ce que je souhaite
profondément mais si on va vers votre
plombé vous ne convaincrez
jamais vous savez dans les années vous
avez gouverné quasiment 15
eurmeo les leçons de pour le coup ça ça
a été un échec je le pense jeentendis
monsieur pi qui déb ave disait qu' plan
B n'était pas stupide donc voyez vous
réfléchissez je trouve ça plutôt pas mal
les
propositionsta
sur ou pas traité de mastrich euro ou
pas euro aucun pays aucune entreprise
aucune famille ne peut vivre en
accumulant des dettes indéfiniment et ce
qu'on entend là autour de la table c'est
assz intéressant on pense toujours que
le salut va venir d'ailleurs il
suffirait demander à l'EUR suffirait de
demander à l'Europe de faire
sauter a de crises
entre7 vous savez ça de crises une crise
é les États-Unis et une crise bancaire
c'est nous qui les avons assumé
alorszonné est-ce que les ban
dans dans les 5 dernières années alors
qu'il n a eu aucun crise aucune crise
autre qu'économique mais différemment en
fonction des différents pays européens
on a encore accumulé 600 milliards
d'euros de dett ça ne peut pas durer pas
ce n'est pas de faire reporter j'allais
dire l'origine de ces problèmes sur les
autres en pensant que les autres vont
effectivement nous accorder de continuer
à nous endetter indéfiniment qu'on
réglera les problèmes vous n'avez pas le
de
rend
devzer qu'il faut effire milliard d'com
pouroi il dit parce que sinon nous
allons vers de très très graves
difficultésut réduire le déficit public
redonner de la compétitivité à
entreprises ce sont les AX ce sont les
axes majeurs proposition fon écoutez
votre candidat qui é un admirateur de
Chavez qui a quand même réussi à
mettreun des pays les plus riches
d'Amérique latine en
faillitem de dire que n'est pas chez
vous ni chez Mélenchon j' chercher je
par
don dire sur l'Europe parce que je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron est le seul candidat
pro européen dans cette campagne vous
savez vous savez en ce moment moi j'ai
l'impression il faut pas asser des
contevérités quand même par que c'est
pible vous écoutez pas du tout ce que je
dis parce que je viens de dire à
l'instant le contraire que c'est un des
désaccords qu'on a avec er
Corel pourquoi selon vous c'est le seul
prouropéen Laur allezy je pense que dans
une époque où en ce moment on voit la
ressurgence de vous êtes peut-être la
seule candidate qui défend cette
Europe je commence à parler vous
m'interrompezoup je parle calmement
écoute voilà ok bon allez-y euh je crois
qu'en ce moment on assiste en Europe à
une progression de mouvements qui sont
des mouvements xénophobes racistes et
cetera et Emmanuel Macron en a
conscience et dit qu'il faut réformer
l'Europe avec une France forte au sein
d'une Europe forte que ça demandera du
temps et qu'il faut repenser l'Europe
parce que l'Europe par rapport à ce qui
se passe aux États-Unis avec Donald
Trump par rapport aussi à ce qui se
passe avec la Russie a besoin d'être uni
et de faire des choses de manière
cohérente par rapport à des dossiers
comme le numérique comme les entreprises
c'est important voilà donc si ça se fait
pas excusez-moi parce que la question
c'est pas d'être pour ou contre l'Europe
une coopération internationale
coopération européenne je pense
qu'autour de la table même même le Front
national estime à certain moment qu'il
faut de l'Europe j'ai entendu donc c'est
pas la question c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'Europe l'Europe c'est donner la main
au marché et c'est des politiques
d'austérité imposé par rapport aux
spécificités de l'économie allemande ou
du moins des possédents Allemands nous
ce que nous disons c'est que qu'est-ce
que vous faites si comme depuis des
années et bien il y a justement euh un
refus discuté euh vous pouvez pas
simplement aller voir Madame Merkel pour
la rassurer et dire qu'à l'avance euh il
y a pas de problème la France continuera
à faire des sacrifices en terme de
dépens publique c'est ce qu'a fait
monsieur Macron hein et en terme de ce
qu'on appelle les la la réforme des
structures on sait ce que c'est c'est
des super lois travail bien donc nous
nous ne sommes pas pour justement
aborder cette question comme ça parce
que sinon je vais vous dire une chose
c'est que l'Union européenne va éclater
de toute manière si elle continue telle
qu'elle est à se tourner contre les
peuples à imposer l' érité le chômage
personne ne peut adhérer à un projet de
Mo- 10 ans social écologique donc si on
veut sauver l'idée d'une coopération
européenne et nous le voulons il faut
repartir justement de ce que la France
peut faire si demain un président de la
République qui veut véritablement
négocier sur la base d'un rapport de
force que la géopolitique continue à
exister prend le pouvoir et donc
Jean-Luc Mélenchon préside ce pays nous
effectivement nous pensons que on ne
peut pas continuer à subir des sacrifice
en terme de d'acquis sociaux en terme de
de de de de salaire en terme deér de BAE
de dépens publi et qu'il faudra
effectivement taper du point sur la
tableisation fiscale sociale
Imposs pas continuer s uneisation
sociale fcale nous sommes le seul espace
géopolitique au
mond
ouvreationalist donc nous sommes pour
une vraie coopération européenne qui
tourne le dos ce aujourd'hui
tour
[Musique]
ut
partir en guerre contre tous les pays du
monde la France par la
con
conurance dans
CEB
je vous propose je vous propose
d'écouter le ministre des Affaires
étrangères le ministre syrien puisque
l'actualité c'est aussi ça la chose
essentielle aujourd' une attaque
chimique plutôt que d'entendre des gens
s'affronter dev faire l'ouverture de
cette émission avec l'attaque chimique
c'est le cas
allez-y on écoute
justement je peux vous assurer une
nouvelle fois que l'armée arabe
syrienne n'a pas utilisé et n'utilisera
jamais ce genre d'arme contre notre
propre
peuple contre nos
enfants pas même contre les terroristes
qui ont tué notre peuple et nos
enfantsie cette attaque chimique contre
un village syrien qui a fait au moins 86
morts imputé au régime de Damas que
préconise Benoît mon le candidat que
vous représentez sur ce plateau pour
résoudre ce conflit syrien écoutez
d'abord euh moi je suis j'aiété je pense
comme tous les Français absolument
choqués par cette attaque honteuse à
laquelle on a assisté ça me fait juste
dire une chose c'est que vraiment quand
je repense à des propos que j'ai entendu
à l'Assemblée nationale des propos que
j'ai entendu sur les ondes sur les
médias en disant il faut traiter avec
Monsieur Assad parce que Monsieur Assad
il est parti de la solution je voilà je
pense qu'il faut que l'on trace faut
tracer des lignes à un moment donné et
on ne peut pas construire une solution
de paix avec un boucher et Monsieur
Assad aujourd'hui plus que jamais a
remontré qu'il était un boucher quelle
est l' ligne défendue par Marine Le Pen
Geoffrey boulet non mais c'est une
attaque épouvantable et évident que les
responsables doivent être sanctionnés
pour ça d'ailleurs il doit y avoir une
enquête claire et et impartial de l'ONU
maintenant monsieur anotan est-ce que
sérieusement on peut se payer le luxe de
ne pas discuter avec un acteur majeur
sur ce terrain parce que si vous si vous
dégagez si je puis dire Bachar al-Assad
et son gouvernement vous mettez qui à la
place on a fait les mêmes expériences en
Irak c'est Saddam Hussein était aussi un
bouché on a fait les mêmes expériences
en libe et ça a donné le cas islamisme
laissez-moi term ça a donnaé le CH
Islamist donc un moment euh il faut
quand même retenir les leçons des des
erreurs du passé et donc si si vous
partez dans une campagne absolument
délirante militaire enue de renverser ce
gouvernement qu'est-ce qu'il reste à la
place répondre à cette question et là
vous aurez les islamiste et donc ce sera
le massacre des minorités religieuses la
fin de toute solution
paand votre candidate elle veut les du
Pass je vous demande répondre à question
peuton se payer le luxeuton se payer le
luxe peuton se payer le luxe monsieur de
pas trer avec les acteurs sur le terrain
je ne crois
pasou vous vous proposez
propose
dansassif plus
graveaujourd'hui d'exposer les minorités
religie je
proposeand
la moi je vais parler de quelque chose
que je connais bien parce que j'ai été
sur ce terrain là il y a des choses qui
ne méritent pas débat ni polémique il y
a une attaque chimique contre une
population civile avec des enfants qui
sont morts il doit y avoir c'est un
crime absolument inacceptable ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron si Emmanuel Macron est
élu comme président il n'aura qu'un but
assurer la sécurité des Français lutter
contre le terrorisme et faire en sorte
qu'on trouve une solution à ce dossier
syrien à ce drame syrien où des milliers
de gens sont morts voilà et je pense que
d'une certaine manière pour rendre
hommage à ces gens qui ont été gazés et
bien il n'y a pas matière à polémique et
c'est cela une démocratie responsable
par rapport à quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est complètement INAC donc
Bach Hassan il ne fait pas partie de la
solution syrienne le régime d'Assad est
criminel il faut la cessation des
combats il faut une transition politique
avec la France qui a une place pour avec
les grandes puissances faire en sorte
que cette transition politique se passe
et il faut une assistance humanitaire
immédiate et moi je ne rentrerai pas ici
dans un débat de petite phras sur le
drame syrien le drame syrien c'est
quelque chose l'histoire nous jugera par
rapport à ce qui se passe et Emmanuel
Macron on a pleinement conscience et je
peux vous dire qu'on en a parlé
aujourd'hui beaucoup au QG d' marche
Éric coocrel la position de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon moi je crois qu'il a changé
d'avis sur cette question fa je pas
qu'elle était je je dire laavis de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je pense que il faut
faire attention sur ce qui se passe
là-bas à ne pas recommettre les erreurs
qui ont été faites depis des années
parce que au nom de la démocratie et au
nom de la lutte contre certains régimes
non seulement ces régimes continu la
démocratie n'a pas fait un Yota de de
pas et par contre on a le nostra on a le
daesh et cetera donc sur la question du
gaz et nous sommes bien placés nous
français puisque nous sommes les
premiers av avoir souffert dans les Ann
au niveau de la Première Guerre mondiale
on doit être absolument intraitable
voilà c'est en dehors c'est une méthode
qui est en dehors de de de tout le droit
international il faut donc tout de suite
favoriser une une enquête de l'ONU et
pour chasser ceux qui l'ont fait quel
qu'il soit que ce soit monsieur Bachar
al-Assad ou d'autres qui le fait donc ça
c'est une règle intangible ensuite il
faut que les choses se passent sous
égites de l'ONU et moi je suis inquiet
de voir Monsieur Trump euh tre en train
d'expliquer que les États-Unis
pourraient à nouveau décider hors toute
résolution de l'ONU de rentrer dans un
conflit en syri alors qu'il disaiit
exactement l'inverse il y a quelques
temps et donc il faut que les choses
soient faites sur sur la base de l'ONU
et nous sommes pour appuyer la
résolution de l'ONU qui a quelques temps
proposer en réalité ce qui a été proposé
depuis des années c'estàd des accords de
Genève et je suis désolé mais comme la
là-bas de toute façon il est quand même
difficile de trouver à part les Kurdes
très certainement de trouver des des
États qui soient meilleurs que d'autres
il faut malheureusement faire en sorte
que les États les tous les bigérant so
autour de la table à une condition
effectivement c'est de proposer que le
vote les urnes parle en Syrie pour
installer un régime démocratique je
voudrais rajouter 15 secondes je
voudrais rajouter 15 secondes quelque
chose sur 15 secondes il faut faire en
sorte que les gens qui commettent ce
genre de crime soi poursuivi et qu'il
n'y ait qu'il ait véritablement une loi
sur l'immunité quand vous avez gazé des
populations et bien on doit vous
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de votre vie
tribun il existe le Tribunal pénal
international donc il y a pas de
problème là-dessus y ce qui s'est passé
là cette monstruosité c'est la
conséquence de l'impéci de l'ONU des
États-Unis qui n'ont rien voulu faire
alors qu'il faut pas se raconter
d'histoire si les États-Unis avaient
voulu il y a quelques années la France
le voulait mais la France ne le pouvait
pas l'Europe est complètement absente et
quand certains disent qu'il faut que la
France sorte de l'Europe on ferait bien
d'y réfléchir dans un monde tel qu'il
est donc c'est l'impérici de la
communauté internationale voilà donc on
a dit qu'on voulait pas discuter avec un
tel on voulait pas discuter avec un tel
résultat la Russie est uné sur place qui
va certainement rendre beaucoup plus
facilelocuteur Bachar alAssad pour lui
écoutez pour une fois il y a une partie
des propos de de d'éc coqurel que je
partage il va bien falloir remettre tout
le monde autour de la table et si Bachar
et laassable est coupable de cette
monstruosité j'espère bien qu'il finira
dans le Tribunal pénal international
mais c'est la unuté internationale qui a
été incapable pendant toutes ces années
et c'est ça le plus grand scandale à
quoi sert l'ONU voilà c'est la question
qu'il faut se poser moi ce que j'ai
envie de dire c'est aussi qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire parce que effectivement
en il y a des choses qui sont du ressort
de la communauté internationale et pas
uniquement de la France mais il y a
aussi des solutions qu'on peut
développer maintenant nous et moi je
vous le dis je pense qu'il faut encore
encore plus au vu de ce massacre il faut
que plus que jamais on mette en place
une politique d'accueil des réfugiés qui
sont menacé par les les gaz chimiques
qui sont menacés par la guerre chaque
jour nous n'avons pas été à la hauteur
ces 5 dernières années quand je vois que
Madame Merkel a permis l'accueil de plus
d'un million de personnes en Allemagne 1
million et qu'en France ça se compte en
milliers ou en dizaines de milliers et
que ça se passe plus mal en France
d'accueillir des dizaines de milliers
que d'accueillir un million en Allemagne
ça m'interroge parce que oui nous
n'avons pas organiser les choses de
manière à ce que les choses se passent
bien quand vous êtes en quand les
réfugés sont en emag ils sont
immédiatement répartis sur le territoire
il y a des cours d'Allemands qui sont
donnés il y a toute une structure
associative qui s'est mis en place
est-ce que nous avons agi dans cette
manière en France
nonéégème ce qu'il faut faire la
priorité des priorités sur le terrain ça
doitre
d'adiqu puissance militaire régionale et
internationale doivent s'associer pour
éradiquer l'État islamique vraiment la
première chose quand l'État islamique
n'existera plus il sera toujours
question de voir ce qu'on fait avec les
gouvernements mais ne nous lançons pas
dans des politiques de virer les
dictateurs à droite à gauche parce que
dans ces caslà qu'est-ce que vous faites
avec l'Arabie Saoud qui
BB
prioritqu l'État islamique pour la
sécurité des Français et la stabilité de
la
région je crois qu'au nom de la
souffrance en ce moment qui se passe sur
le en Syrie avec ces milliers de gens
qui sont tués sous nos yeux il faut
qu'on soit tous d'accord pour eux pour
se dire que la paix se construit par le
dialogue par la tolérance par la
solidarité par mettre les gens autour
d'une table et essayer quel que soient
nos différences de trouver une solution
et je peux vous assurer que si Emmanuel
Macron est élu c'est ce qu'il fera et
bien merci merci à tous les CIN d'avoir
participé à ce débat particulièrement
animé il est tout juste 19h toujours en
direct sur Public Sénat tout de suite le
rappel des titres Washington accuse
d'amas au lendemain de l'attaque
chimique en Syrie qui a tué 86 personnes
dont au moins 20 enfants Moscou récuse
ses accusations tandis que français
britannique pointte également du doigt
le régime le régime de Bachar al-Assad
analyse à suivre le premier secrétaire
du PS Jean-Christophe cambadellis lance
un appel à l'unité à la loyauté derrière
Benoît Hamont il refuse la panique
démocratique alors que ce multiplient
les ralliments des l'UPS en faveur
d'Emmanuel Macron nous serons en direct
de Solferino dans un instant la décision
de fermer fen reporté le conseil
d'administration de def devait se
prononcer aujourd'hui mais la plus
vieille centrale nucléaire de France
devrait encore attendre sur la pression
de l'État aucun accord n'a pu être
trouvé on en parle avec mes invités à la
fin de cette édition et je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez réagir en direct le
hashtag présidentiel
360 pour nous accompagner ce soir
Saveria rejecte toujours en direct du
siège du Parti socialiste rut Solferino
à Paris le multiplex c'est tout de
suite
[Musique]
l'administration Trump durcit le ton
face au régime de Bachar al-Assad rendu
responsable de l'attaque chimique
perpétrée au nord de la Syrie les
États-Unis soulignent aussi la
responsabilité morale de Moscou et lois
Grégoire à la Une de Libération
aujourd'hui l'effroid
86 personnes dont 30 enfants sont morts
lors d'une attaque chimique malgré ces
images le président du kremelin juge
inacceptabl les accusations sans preuve
selon lui des pays occidentaux le régime
syrien rejette également en bloc et
persiste il ne serait pas responsable de
l'attaque chimique en Syrie depuis hier
une nouvelle voix se fait entendre
Donald Trump hausse le ton et menace
d'intervenir en
Syrie c'est tout à fait possible et je
vais vous dire c'est déjà le cas mon
attitude vis-à-vis de la Syrie et
d'Assad a nettement changé hier
l'ambassadrice américaine u brandit ses
images d'enfant syrien elle accuse
Moscou de dédoiner le régime de
Damas si la Russie a l'influence qu'elle
prétend avoir en Syrie il faut qu'elle
s'en
serve il faut qu'elle metent un terme à
ces actes atroces combien d'enfants
devront encore mourir avant que la
Russie ne s'en
soucie le climat se tend entre les
États-Unis et la Russie vous avez
aujourd'hui un pays qui est la Russie
qui a une stratégie très claire très
cohérente de soutien au régime pour
s'assurer que le régime tienne en en
alliance avec l'Iran et à l'inverse vous
avez des pays occidentaux qui font des
actes diplomatique mais finalement assez
peu d'action sur le terrain et donc dans
un contexte comme ça l'équilibrere des
forces est largement favorable à la
Russie les Nations unies dans le
cirriens ont fait très peu hein c'est
vraiment un des grands échecs
historiques des Nations Unies
aujourd'hui des autopsies en Turquie
confirment bien l'utilisation d'armes
chimique par le régime syrien mais
combien de temps encore le Conseil de
sécurité sera-t-il le simple sp atateur
de ces massacres et on en vient
maintenant à l'actualité politique en
France et cet appel de Jean-Christophe
cambadellis premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste à plus de loyauté envers
Benoît amamont le bureau national est
réuni en ce moment sur place on retrouve
tout de suite
saiac et bien l'objet Delphine de ce
bureau national ce sont les investitures
au législatif faut-il sanctionner oui ou
non ce qui soutiennent Emmanuel Macron
oui c'est en tout cas ce que veut ce que
demande l'entourage de Benoît amamont
une réaction sévère une clarification
alors jusqu'à présent Jean-Christophe
cambadilis le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste a plutôt opposé une fin
de non recevoir pas de chasse aux
sorcièrees pas de saint-barelémi et bien
à l'instant christian Paul le député
socialiste vient de nous annoncer le
contraire en sortant tout juste du
bureau national ce qui soutienent paren
ou même vote Emmanuel Macron
n'obtiendront pas l'investiture du Parti
socialiste ce qui inclurait donc ce qui
votent ce qui inclurait donc l'ancien
Premier ministre manuel Vass je vous
propose d'écouter le député socialiste
crrisampul le Parti socialiste
n'investit pas n'investira pas ceux qui
soutiennent Emmanuel Macron qui le
parine ou qui appelle à voter pour lui
ça a été dit très clairement par
Jean-Christophe cambadellis
voilàu écoutez ensuite ça se déclinera
dans chaque département mais je crois
que son propos était était clair et il a
été entendu voilà donc avec une certaine
gravité mais je crois que dans un moment
comme celui-là il faut de la clarteté on
peut pas amuser la galerie en ayant un
pied au Parti socialiste et un pied qui
soutient un autre candidat Benoît Hamont
qui est encore une fois le candidat
d'une primaire
citoyenne voilà donc Delphine le Parti
socialiste qui ne devrait pas investir
les soutiens d'Emmanuel Macron une
position c'est e à l'inverse de ce que
prenait jusqu'à présent Jean-Christophe
Cambadélis vous l'aurez compris en tout
cas Delphine la bataille des
législatives et bien elle a d'ors et
déjà commencé merci beaucoup Saveria
avec Quentin calm sur place la décision
était sans doute trop sensible
politiquement à moins de 3 semaines du
premier tour de la présidentielle le
conseil d'administration d'EDF a préféré
reporter le vote qui devait entériner la
fermeture de Fessenheim la plus ancienne
centrale nucléaire du parc français
Sandra CERC
plusieurs centaines de salariés venus
mettre la pression jusqu'au bout devant
le siège de DF et finalement la
fermeture de Fessenheim a été reportée
cet après-midi par le conseil
d'administration de l'entreprise une
première victoire pour les salariés
inquiet par les 2000 emplois menacés
alors que pour eux la centrale est
encore en état de fonctionner c'est
quand même une canta nucléaire qui qui
était validé comme étant sûr par
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
aujourd'hui on a la validation pour des
exploitations pendant 10 ans donc il y a
aucune raison technique de fer Faem
aujourd'hui donc la seule raison c'est
une raison politique c'était une
promesse de François Hollande un bras de
fer entre l'État et EDF qui dure depuis
plusieurs années la direction a toujours
traîné des pieds à tel point que ce
matin encore cgolen royale les a rappelé
à l'ordre nous avons maintenant des
centrales qui arrivent à échéance de
leur durée de vie à 40 ans de leur durée
de vie et donc investir dans ces
centrales va coûter beaucoup plus cher
qu'investir soit dans les énergies
renouvelables soit dans les économies
d'énergie et par conséquent l'intérêt de
l'entreprise ça n'est pas de ralentir ce
processus la ministre de l'Environnement
souhaitait prendre au plus vite un
décret pour fermer Fessenheim à la mise
en service de LEPR de flamandville prévu
fin 2018 la balle est maintenant dans le
camp du futur président de la République
seul Marine Le Pen et François Fillon
souhaite maintenir fenheim en activité
th tranu m'a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir avec vous on va tenter d'y voir
plus clair he sur cette question du
nucléaire en France combien coûterait le
maintien ou la sortie c'est une question
très compliquée et oui en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'en la matière et
bien on est certain de rien tellement il
y a des paramètres à prendre en compte
je vais donc simplement vous parler des
résultats de certaines études qui ont
tenté ce difficile exercice du du
chiffrage et on va commencer par une
étude dont on a beaucoup parlé celle de
l'Institut Montaigne think tank libéral
pour qui la sortie complète du nucléaire
d'ici 2035 coûterait de 117 milliards
d'euros alors comment s'explique ce coût
selon l'institut Montaine il y a d'abord
l'investissement dans des capacités de
production alternatives il y a
l'adaptation du réseau et
l'indemnisation deedf une étude qui dès
qu'elle a été publiée a été contestée
par exemple l'association negawatts a
tout de suite dénoncé un calcul très
erroné ouais alors ce sont surtout des
chiffres qu'il faut comparer au coût de
la poursuite du nucléaire TH et oui
effectivement poursuivre dans notre mix
énergétique actuel et bien ça coûte
aussi selon la Cour des comptes le grand
carénage qui permet de prolonger la vie
de nos 58 centrales nucléaires actuelles
au-delà de 40 ans et le maintenance
jusqu'en 2030 cela coûterait 100
milliards d'euros et si tel est le cas
si on a bien fait ce grand carénage il
faudra quand même avoir de nouvelles
centrales ensuite et le PDG de DF
Jean-Bernard levvi prévoit la mise en
service de 30 à 40 pr de 2030 à 2050 si
on considère qu'unpr c'est 10 milliards
et demi en moyenne et bien ça revient en
prenant la fourchette basse à 315
milliards d'euros sauf si bien sûr il y
a des économies d'échelle à ça il faut
aussi ajouter bien sûr le coût du
démantellement des anciennes centrales
la gestion à long terme des déchets et
cetera et cela c'est 60 milliards
d'euros toujours selon EDF un coout très
sous-évalué à estimer un rapport
parlementaire de l'Assemblée nationale
dont la rapporteur était l'écologiste
Barbara romagnon ou est-ce qu'il y a des
études qui ont comparé les coûts et bien
oui il y a 5 ans avant la présidentielle
celle de 2012 il y avait une association
Global Chance qui réunit des
scientifiques qui pour beaucoup
travaillent dans le domaine de l'énergie
qui plaident en faveur d'un
développement plus équilibré ils ont
estimé que ça coûtait et bien aussi cher
de maintenir le mix énergétique actuel
que de sortir du nucléire en 20 ans pour
eux ça coûte entre 428 et 504 milliards
d'euros quel que soit le scénario mais
ils estiment toutefois que sur le long
terme le renouvelable serait plus
rentable avec de très faibles coûts de
fonctionnement dis style et de
remplacement alors que le
réinvestissement dans le nucléaire
créera je les cite toujours un fardeau
avec de lourdes charges de
démantellement et de gestion des déchets
merci beaucoup Tam pour toutes ces
précisions alors quel avenir pour
fessanim comment interpréter ce nouvel
épisode du feuilleton nucléaire c'est le
thème de notre
[Musique]
débat et pour en parler quatre invités
m'ont rejoint sur ce plateau Charlotte
mijon bonsoir vous êtes porte-parole du
Réseau Sortir du Nucléaire merci d'être
avec nous j'accueille également
MarieClaire bonsoir vous êtes
porte-parole de la Fédération nationale
des mines et de l'énergie pour la CGT
merci d'être avec nous Thomas Porchet
bonsoir vous êtes économiste auteur de
20 idées reçues sur l'énergie aux
éditions de becc université et enfin
j'accueille Boris log bonsoir vous êtes
porte-parole de la société française
d'énergie nucléaire également rédacteur
en chef de cette revue La Revue générale
nucléaire merci à tous les quatre
première question pour vous MarieClaire
CAO que c'est il passé cet après-midi on
attendait cette décision du conseil
d'administration de DF et finalement
elle est une nouvelle fois reportée ce
qui s'est passé c'est que depuis
quelques jours il y a une pression folle
et inacceptable du gouvernement sur le
conseil d'administration de DF pour
essayer de faire voter j'allais dire à
l'arracher une demande d'abrogation de
fonctionnement de la centrale nucléaire
de fenheim tout ça pour pouvoir sortir
un décret et dire que politiquement
monsieur handolland a rempli au moins un
de ses des engagements donc les salariés
étaient quand même assez furieux de ça
c'est pour ça ailleurs qu'ils se sont
rassemblés assez nombreux devant le
conseil d'administration et heureusement
les administrateurs indépendants n'ont
pas cédé au chantage honteux du
président de la République et de Madame
Hollande et n'ont pas accepté de voter
et et d'ailleurs je voudrais dire
là-dessus que je suis quand même assez
stupéfaite des déclarations de Madame
Hollande dans la presse qui les a mis en
garde de façon assez explicite alors que
c'est les administrateurs indépendants
qui sont là pour veiller aux intérêts de
l'entreprise et qui a été dire des
contevérités dans des médias publices en
disant que la centrale nucléaire de fael
nétait pas sûr donc ça veut dire qu'elle
remet en cause en tant que ministre le
rôle de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
et qu'il faudrait provisionner pour la
mettre au normees de sûreté alors que
nombre de sûreté post Fukushima ont déjà
été faites donc c'est quand même un
épisode qui est vraiment très troublant
Charlotte mon il y a ce contexte
politique on est à quelques semaines du
premier tour de la présidentielle ça a
pesé dans la décision d'aujourd'hui pour
nous ce qu'il faut faut voir
indépendamment de tout calcul politique
de toute promesse c'est que ce qu'on
nous propose actuellement c'est de
qu'une centrale qui est vieille et qui
est dangereuse qui est en fin de vie et
dont d'ailleurs les deux réacteurs sont
actuellement arrêtés il faut le rappeler
notamment le réacteur numéro 2 sur
décision de l'autorité de sûrté
nucléaire donc qu'on nous propose que
cette centrale ne soit définitivement
arrêtée que quand entrera en service un
réacteur qui est dangereux et dont on
sait qu'il comporte une cuve défectueuse
donc pour nous c'est pas une surprise
mais c'est quand même surréaliste ou
elle n'est plus viable cette centrale
NUC plusurs choses à répondre à ce que
vient de dire Madame mon la première
c'est qu'on peut pas dire que c'est un
outil qui soit vieux ça a été inspecté
par l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui
dans son dernier rapport vous venez de
la citer l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
prend en exemple fenheim comme une des
centrales les plus sûres du parc
français ça aussi pour vous dire qu'il y
a eu 300 millions d'euros qui ont été
investis dans la centrale pour la
rénover complètement et pour que
justement elle puisse continuer à
produire une électricité qui n'éimit pas
de CO2 qui ne produit pas de particules
fine et qui en plus produit de
l'électricité qui est pas cher autre
exemple que je voulais vous dire aussi
c'est si on prend faenheim il y a sa
sœur jumelle qui existe aux États-Unis
donc de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
elle s'appelle Bever Valley et cette
centrale nucléaire là elle va
fonctionner jusqu'à 60 ans et les
Américains étudient même la possibilité
pour leur centrale nucléaire de type
Bever Valley d'exploiter jusqu'à 80 ans
thomas Porcher c'est vrai que c'est une
situation compliquée d'un côté il y a
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui n'est
pas contre cette fermeture est-ce que on
a encore besoin en France d'un point de
vue de la production d'énergie
d'électricité de cette centrale de fhe
moi je pense qu'on a déjà une une
production d'électricité qui est
extrêmement concentrée sur le nucléaire
pratiquement 80 % de notre production
d'électricité vient du nucléaire il y a
la loi de transition énergétique qui est
tombée qui veut baisser cette part du
nucléaire à 50 % et aujourd'hui on vient
de voir que on fermera Fessenheim à
partir du moment où on aura un autre
réacteur le Pr qui remplacera fonim donc
on remplace du nucléaire par du
nucléaire ce qui prouve qu'on ne pourra
pas respecter la loi de transition
énergétique qui pose quand même un
problème après de nombreux candidats à
la présidentielle s'y engage pourtant en
développant les les énergie alternative
et renouvable exactement on verra après
qui gagnera et qui ce qui sera fait
parce que je rappelle qu'holande avait
promis de fermer F sous le quinena et il
a rien prévu pour les employés justement
de de de de cette centrale nucléaire il
a rien prévu en terme de transition de
remplacement d'énergie pour pouvoir
fermer c'est une espèce de décret qui
est pris très rapidement et vous l'avez
très bien dit et je pense que si on
ferme une centrale il faut vraiment
prévoir une euh pour les salariés une
formation et et et et d'autres débouchés
mais également pour pour les la
production d'énergie les remplacé par
d'autres énergies et jouer aussi sur la
demande via le la rénovation des
bâtiments là on voit qu'il y a de
l'amateurisme là-dessus on est d'accord
mais il y a un choix de société à faire
on pourra comparer les chiffre tant
qu'on veut on pourra comparer les
compétitivités les coûts sont croissants
plutôt dans le nucléaire même si ils ont
été pendant très longtemps avantageux ce
qui a fait qu'on a eu le coût de
l'énergie le plus faible c'est le choix
de société qu'on veut certains pays
l'Allemagne ont décidé de sortir du
nucléaire Taiwan petite île s sort du
nucléaire a décidé de le faire nous nous
avons décidé de le faire par une loi
certains candidats le proposent s'il y a
une loi il faut la respecter et s'il
faut la respecter bah il va falloir
fermer des réacteurs et les remplacer
par des unités de production
renouvelable Marie cler Caou est-ce
qu'elle est vraiment dangereuse cette
centrale nucléaire VO moi je suis très
troublée mais même ce que par je viens
d'entendre he c'est-à-dire que des
personnes alors que je respecte mais ça
puis ti la centrale est dangereuse moi
très franchement ça me choque
profondément pourquoi on a en France une
autorité de sûreté nucléaire
indépendante il y a 487 personnes qui
l'ASN s'appuie sur l'IRSN l'Institut de
radioprotection de srté nucléaire dans
lequel il y a 1000 ingénieurs chercheurs
technicien qui travaillent ces gens
travaillent et viennent de dire fait
peut fonctionner pendant 10 ans alors
moi j'aimerais bien savoir sur quelles
études s'appui des gens comme Madame
Royale ou comme vous-même qui veneit de
dire elle est dangereuse je trouve que
c'est très perturbant parce que du coup
ça veut dire que l'autorité de sûrté
nucléaire n'est pas pertinente dans ce
cas-là ben allons allons jusqu'au bout
on va la dissoudre on arrête de payer
des gens pour rien sur le second point
sur le bouquet énergétique bien
évidemment nous syndicalement on n'est
pas des militants d'une technologie donc
ce qu'on est c'est des militants pour
répondre aux besoins tout en prenant en
compte les enjeux climatiques donc ce
que nous souhaitons c'est qu'on ait un
bouquet énergétique qui réponde aux
enjeux économiques environnementaux et
sociaux donc qu'il évolue au fur et à
mesure des avancées technologiques en
incorporant des filières d'énergies
renouvelables on y est tout fait
favorable par contre aujourd'hui on est
dans un cas où on nous demande de fermer
de manière politique une usine qui
ramène 1 million d'euros par jour à
l'entreprise EDF qui émet comme ça a été
dit enfin qui produitélectricité à Bakou
sans émettre de CO2 et qui emploie dans
la région d'Alsace 850 personnes donc
entre 3 à 4000 personnes dans le tissu
industriel c'est pas rien quand même on
parle on parle quand même de pas rien
par Charlotte mon pourquoi vous
basez-vous justement pour juger cette
centrale dangereuse contrairement à ce
que préconise la déjà tout simplement ce
que dit laasn elle-même je pense que si
l'ASN a suspendu le certificat
d'épreuves du générateur de vapeur du
réacteur numéro 2 c'est qu'il y a une
raison à ça si l'ASN a avoué nêtre pas
très contente pas très contente qu'on
lui ait caché certaines choses lorsque
EDF EDF a fait passer une fuite d'eau de
100 m CB d'eau pour un défaut
d'étanchéité je pense que là
s raison d'être un petit peu en colère
et par ailleurs on peut dire l'Autorité
de sûreté nucléaire est indépendante on
vient d'avoir un démenti flagrant il y a
eu une révélation donc il y a à peine
une semaine vous l'avez vu sur la cuve
de LEPR comme quoi l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire était au courant depuis 2005
que la cuve de le père pouvait comporter
des défauts parce que l'on faisait
n'importe quoi à l'usine du creusau elle
le savait elle n'a pas voulu ou elle n'a
pas pu agir commenta et elle a
apparemment subi de fortes pressions de
DF et eva pour que cette cuve soit
homologuée donc à partir de là laasn
elle-même demande plus de moyens elle
demande plus d'agents elle demande plus
de pouvoir de sanction donc on peut dire
qu'elle est indépendante mais est-ce
qu'elle se retrouve dans un rapport de
force suffisant pour pouvoir imposer ce
qu'elle souhaite je
pe laisse-moi finir s'il vous plaît
est-ce qu'elle se retrouve dans un
rapport de force suffisant quand je me
souviens très bien il y a encore
quelques mois j'étais à une audience
alors que DF était en justice par
rapport justement à des infractions qui
viennent d'être sanctionné à la centrale
de Fessenheim une une canalisation qui a
été réparée n'importe comment et qui
s'est rompu sous les yeux des
inspecteurs de l'ASN sous les yeux des
inspecteurs de ASN juste à 1 m de là où
elle avait été réparée alors même que DF
avait promis qu'il feraient les
réparations et qu'ils analyseraient ceux
qui n'ont pas fait et quand on voit que
les représentants de DF essayent
d'intimiter l'autorité de Sté charoton
pard pour que la parole
CIRC il faut revenir sur des des
éléments assez concrets du débat encore
une fois l'autorité de sûrté nucléaire a
dit que cette centrale nucléaire là
après des examens après les
réinvestissements qui ont été faits
pouvait fonctionner encore 10 années
supplémentaire et puis au-delà de ces 10
ans il y aura d'autres examensur
défectueux allez-y fin si je peux me
permettre et vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de ces moyens et tout ça on a
bien vu et donc Thomas peut aussi en
être témoin au début de l'année ce qu'il
s'est passé c'est que l'autorité de
sûrté nucléaire a demandé l'arrêt d'une
dizaine de réacteurs pour des
inspections et donc ça démontre bien
aussi à la fois son endance vis-à-vis de
ce que vous appelez vous despressions
mais dont vous n'avez pas la preuve et
sur donc indépendante et qu'elle a les
moyens et qu'elle ne prend aucun risque
donc elle applique à la lettre le
principe de précaution qui de dire à la
moindre réserve elle préfère arrêter la
tranche plutôt de que de faire couririt
vraiment les moyens si elle en avait
vraiment les moyens est-ce qu'elle
aurait pu obtenir vraiment l'arrêt de la
production de la cuve est-ce que c'est
quand même surréaliste ce qui s'est
passé à flamandville désolé d'insister
sur ce point là mais ça veut dire que
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire a adressé
un nombre important de demandes à Areva
pour avoir des résultats détest sur la
cuve elle n'a pu les avoir qu'une fois
la cuve installé porch on peut pas
parler de de moyens d'agir dans ces
caslà je je me permets enfin l'énergie
est un choix politique le nucléaire ça a
été un choix politique ça le général de
Gaulle voilà a voulu le plan nucléaire
c'était un choix politique donc en
sortir est aussi un choix politique je
vous rappelle que deff ne va pas très
bien Areva ne va pas bien non plus de
champions cl vont pas très bien ou ils
vont pas très bien enfin tous les cas
moi je pense qu'ils vont pas très bien
pas à cause des salariés comme Emmanuel
Macron mais à cause justement d'une
vision stratégique que l'État n'a plus
aujourd'hui si on veut garder EDF et
conserver votre emploi je pense qu'il va
falloir quand même faire quelque chose
et d'autres emploi beaucoup d'emplois
a00is dans nuclé voilà et donc moi je
pense qu'il faut opérer cette transition
et faire justement de DF un champion des
renouvelables parce que les pars de
marchés sont à prendre
là est déjà le le le premier producteur
d'énergie renouvelable d'Europe d'ord
une entreprise du nucléaire avant d'être
du renouvelable il faut ça
devineion t en même temps Alley parce
que les parts de marché sont à prendre
là au niveau européen comme au niveau de
la loi de la transition donc aujourd'hui
le gouvernement a décidé de baisser la
part du nucléaire donc voilà on prend
acte et c'est quand même grave
aujourd'hui que ce soit EDF une société
publique qui décide à la place des choix
politiques normalement c'est l'inverse
le général de Go il a pas demandé à F
non il a décidé pour F et là il faudrait
que le
politiquef pas l'versose que je voudrais
pas laisser croire c'est que si EDF est
en mauvaise santé financière ou en
mauvaise état ce que je ce dont je suis
d'accord ça sera à cause du nucléaire
entre autes le problème non le problème
bah écoutez je suis désolé là on va pas
être d'accord le problème c'est la
libéralisation du secteur énergétique
qui est en train pour laquelle
d'ailleurs beaucoup ont voté de
politique qui est en train de mettre une
pagaille sans nom en France et en Europe
qui nous met pas à l'abri à l'avenir de
la caout et de hausse massif de tarifs
parce qu'aujourd'hui je peux vous donner
des exemples très précis à partir don on
avait des entreprise EDF GDF monopole
national d'électricité et de gaz qui est
qui était des optimums
technicoéconomiques qui ont été
complètement désoptimisé avec la
concurrence on a mis d'un argent fou par
la fenêtre un gaspillage et c'est à
cause de ça qu'on a un problème c'est à
cause de la libéralisation de la conur
un petit mot 5 secondes je suis d'accord
avec vous la libéralisation a fait mal à
toutes nos grand entreprises mais eDF va
quand même plus mal que GDF que ngj
pardon et que Total globalement ENF elle
va elle sorti du 440 et cetera elle va
beaucoup plus mal donc il y a pas que la
libéralisation qui apporté aussi la
stratégie-on prend des risques est-ce
qu'on prend des risques pour les
salariés est-ce qu'on prend des risques
humain en maintenant cette centrale
ouverte au non et bien danger économique
selon vous non je pense plutôt l'inverse
en fait on a parlé de transition
énergétique tout à l'heure la transition
énergétique aussi qu'est-ce qu'elle dit
la loi c'est qu'il faut réduire nos
émissions de CO2 un des moyens d' par
venir on peut tous être d'accord
là-dessus c'est les chiffres qui sont
établis par le GC qui est l'organisme de
référence dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et qui liste en
fait les quatre principales technologies
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
parmi elles il y a le nucléaire la
France est un des champions de de du
monde des des pays industriels qui
n'émit pas de CO2 pour vous donner un
seul ch il faudra bien fermer des
centrales si on veut en fait justement
c'est ce que je vous dis en fait
l'objectif l'objectif c'est pas les 50 %
pour les 50% l'objectif c'est de se
passer des énergies fossiles en tout cas
de de
réduire réduire V lecture de la loi ça
mais B ou c'est une des priorités de
réduire les émissions de CO2 et un moyen
d'y parvenir c'est d'électrifier les
usages de développer massivement les
énergies renouvelables mais de garder
aussi notre notre notre parc nucléaire
qui nous permet d'être le pays du G7
donc une grande puissance qui émet pas
de CO2 dans sa production
d' c'est faux de dire que l'on n'émet
pas de CO2 vous voulez dire que les
mines d'uranum ça ça n'émet pas de CO2
l'extraction et bien il y a des calculs
qui ont été
faits 60 g de CO2 par kilow à peu près
d'accord combien pour le charbon combien
pour le gaz et bien je vous parler des
énergies renouvelables je vous parlais
de système
énergétique dire ce que je veux dire
c'est que tous les calculs sérieux sur
des scénarios qui permettent d'atteindre
les objectif de la loi de transition
énergétique vous prenez le scénario ngaw
vous prenez les différents scénarios qui
ont été élaborés bien ils prennent en
compte oui le scénario prennent en
compte une sortie du nucléaire et vous
ne pouvez pas à la fois développer les
énergies renouvelables développer les
économies d'énergie qui sont les vrais
moyens les deux principaux moyens de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre
souligné par le GC par le GC
lui-même lui-même déclare que que le
nucléaire ne peut jouer qu'un rôle
marginal je suis
désolé avec le rapport du invite à lire
justement il y a 1200 rapports qui ont
été étudiés par le GC 1200 d'accord
parmi lesquels le scénario ngawat
notamment qu'est-ce que dis ce 1200 et
il y en a que 8 scénarios qui permettent
d'atteindre les objectifs de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
c'està-dire limiter l'augmentation de de
de de la température globale de la terre
à 2 degr il y en a que 8 sur les 1200
qui parviennent sans énergie nucléaire
ce que je dis là on peut il y a des
scénarios effectivement mais simplement
c'est prendre un risque
important et de rater l'objectif aussi
qui est de lutter contre le Pr le risque
important que l'on prend c'est de se
retrouver avec un accident un accident
qu'on ne saura pas gérer ça on l'a vu au
Japon qui était pourtant l'un des pays
les plus développés du monde un accident
qui nous coûterait plusieurs points de
PIB si on veut juste compter en économie
un accident qui fait ferait que les
priorités en terme de lutte contre le
changement climatique passerait
totalement en second plan donc ce risque
là est-ce qu'on veut le prendre nous
probabilité quand même plus de risque
d'avoir un accident que n'importe quel
autre pays pour la bonne et simple
raison que nous avons c'est nous sommes
le pays qui avons le plus de central
nucléaires par habitant alors les les
les trois accidents majeurs il y en a eu
deux quand même qui ont eu lieu dans des
pays très développés les États-Unis et
le japonin après on voit toujours les
rapport aprèscoup hein d'ailleurs comme
dans les accidents de di pooiteur
horizon de la de de cette plateforme
pétrolière après coup on se rend compte
toujours que le risque zéro n'existe pas
donc ça il faut quand même le dire même
si l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire pour
le coup peut-être sérieuse il y a quand
même le risque qui est plus élevé qu'
alors très rapidement vous aurez le mot
de la fin Marie CLA parce qu'on arrive
au terme de cette émission il est réel
ce risque d'avoir un accident si on
maintient ouvert non mais si vous voulez
nous on a on a un principe c'est qu'on a
une autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui dit
si un réacteur peut continuer à
fonctionner ou pas et dans quelles
conditions par contre je suis désolé le
risque du réchauffement climatique il
est très réel les climatologues nous
alertent et ils disent c'est tout de
suite qu'il faut agir sinon on va dans
le mur or si on n'agit pas tout de suite
si on fait comme l'Allemagne
c'est-à-dire qu'on privilégie la sortie
du nucléaire et qu'on émet plus de gaz à
effet de C dans l'atmosphère en
utilisant du charbon et la liinite et
ben ce qu'on fait c'est que on repousse
plus tard la question du réchauffement
climatique et on va être devant des
migrations massives de population soit
qu' nuront plus soit qu' n'auront plus
d'eau soit qu' auront des territoires
qui sont submergés par l'eau et je sais
pas comment on fera avec des
gensue à réduire ses émissions de gaz et
effet de ser je veux juste vous dire que
même le président de l'Autorité de
merci on vous mettra pas d'accord sur ce
plateau ce so et reconna le risque
d'accident majeur merci à tous les
quatre c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'y avoir participé merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi à 22h vous retrouvez
pinno pour l'émission On va plus loin
bonne soirée à tous sur public
[Musique]
sén